she was eliminated two sets to one by
Australian Taylor tomjenovich who was
two years old when Williams turned
professional in 1995. Williams has won a
record 23 Grand Slam titles well her
sheer athleticism powerful servant
strategic Sense on the tennis court have
earned Serena Williams a place in the
pantheon of sports history and as a
figure in popular culture now she
appears to be retiring from tennis but
as Rob Reynolds reports Williams is not
about to fade away and a warning his
report contains flash photography
[Applause]
Serena Williams dominated women's tennis
winning 23 singles Grand Slams the first
when she was just 17. along the way she
and her sister Venus inspired a
generation of young players especially
women of color I mean I grew up watching
her I mean that's the reason why I play
tennis and you know tennis being
predominantly white sport it definitely
helped a lot
um because I saw somebody look like me
in her decades in the spotlight Williams
became much more than an athlete she was
and is a cultural phenomenon they should
put herself out much more broadly as a
celebrity personality the new typical
athlete is able to do but that begins
with her dominant place in sport since
2011 Williams has been a Goodwill
Ambassador for the UN children's agency
UNICEF visiting developing countries to
promote education and sports part of her
commitment may come from her own
family's Financial struggles when she
was a child
this gritty South La neighborhood is
where the Williams sisters got their
start playing on those tennis courts
right over there now that she's leaving
professional tennis Serena Williams will
have a future full of ventures in
philanthropy fashion and Hollywood
Williams reportedly is in discussions
with a film studio to Executive produce
a biographical series about her and her
sister she did not want to be defined
solely by her tennis brand so she
reached out and uh and placed herself in
in fashion and in clothing lines she
also had a child and so she promoted
health and wellness for mothers in
addition to athletic wear and wellness
products Williams has dozens of
lucrative endorsement deals from
promoting Gatorade to fronting for a
fancy Swiss watch company all part of a
carefully cultivated Public Image
Williams may be leaving the court but
she will be part of popular culture and
commerce for years to come Rob Reynolds
Al Jazeera Los Angeles